so there was a very particularly
important meeting because of the
humanitarian aid package the adoption of
one of the most important agreements
that we have at a moment between our in
the institutions the inter institutional
agreement on better lawmaking and of
course we have looked very seriously at
the preparation for the European Council
at the end of of this week one of the
first points on the General Affairs
Council agenda today was the approval of
the European emergency aid mechanism
this new emergency instrument can be
used to provide humanitarian assistance
on EU territory there is help for Greece
is needed to accommodate large groups of
men women and children the humanitarian
aid is intended to ensure that refugees
can be provided in their basic needs as
water food medicine and shelter but in
fact the support for Greece can also be
materialized immediately then I think
second point very important
institutional agreement on battle row
making I'm very happy that under this
presidency but with a lot of praise to
our predecessors and there is now this
in institutional agreement between the
European Parliament the European
Commission and the council this must
sound like your lingo too many European
citizens and frankly it is but I think
nevertheless it's a gate chiefland and
crucial for a smooth-running machine
because that's what citizens expect from
us and of course we have looked very
seriously at the preparation for the
European Council at the end of of this
week our common goal is to manage the
flow of migrants and refugees and at the
key element for all I think present this
morning is to destroy the bus the
business model of the smugglers
therefore as you know we want to create
a deal with Turkey to enter the
irregular uncontrolled and extremely
dangerous sea route I am a relatively
optimistic relatively optimistic about
the possibility to come to a good
package deal
the end of this week I think the
attitude of all members of the council
this morning was constructive I think
for all countries it was underlined that
we are now going into the direction of
having a very competent strategy because
it involves all elements that are
important to manage the flow of refugees
that is to say a diamond with Turkey the
second one is the solidarity towards
surgeries the third is the whole issue
of ways through ending of the waves
through I should say and the balcon
route and the fourth element is
intra-european solidarity to ensure that
is a voluntary resettlement program from
Greece and Turkey